all right so for the last panel
it's the tim dillon podcast
[Applause]
tim dillon
let's hear it for tim yeah
yeah yeah does this work yeah that's the
kind of welcome i like
everybody we we got a great
paddle everybody stick around
you ready one announce everybody we'll
announce the next guy let's do it
rolling uh tyler and cameron wrinkle
boss run with uh
uh gemini cam tyler cameron wigglemos
everybody
they are here with us grab some seats
and jake paul jake paul everybody
thank you everybody
go let's go let's go yeah it's okay just
sit down
yeah everybody and elon musk no i'm
kidding
wouldn't that be good you'd kill him if
we brought him in here you'd kill him
i know you animals would murder that man
all right good to be here are you guys
excited
about whatever just happened with el
salvador
how exciting is that i don't know what
happened but something
if apparently if you don't own bitcoin
in el salvador they're going to kill you
and that's good i don't know but
what explain what just happened guys
that what
do you guys know i i didn't hear it
actually
what happened they're accepting uh
bitcoin as a currency now
they're accepting bitcoin as currency in
el salvador that's pretty [ __ ] cool
right let's go yeah and tesla's not
so what'd you say tesla's not right
what tesla is not accepting tesla's not
accepting it no
no no we're we're bullish on el salvador
here [ __ ] tesla
that's right el salvador is the future
tesla is not i'm about to fight quote
elon musk next
yeah right jake do you own any bitcoin
yeah of course of course
i bought my first bitcoin eight years
ago when i was 16. it was at a hundred
dollars stop playing with me
[ __ ] yeah eight wait eight years ago
when you were 16
for a hundred dollars yes sir [ __ ] yeah
i put my whole uh landscaping earnings
and vine brand deal earnings into
bitcoin i had no idea what was going to
happen
but best investment to date yeah you
were landscaping eight years ago
that is correct you've had a very
interesting run
uh yeah to say the least it's been it's
been a roller coaster from vine
to youtube to disney channel to
rapping to knocking people out yeah
are you excited about your brother and
floyd tomorrow
yeah look i'm excited right it's it's a
it's an amazing event such a spectacle
i'm sure a lot of people here are going
i'm nervous
man like i get more nervous for for when
my brother's fighting versus when i'm
fighting because
you know i can't control anything that
that that now
are you nervous about logan getting hurt
are you nervous about what are you
nervous about look
i i think just anything in general right
like he's fighting one of the best
boxers in the history of the sport and i
know he's prepared
he's done everything right he's trained
uh non-stop trained his ass off
and this kid can fight but you're going
up against
floyd mayweather which is no joke and uh
you know anything can happen in that
ring and to see your family member in
there it's quite literally
a death match you know so uh to
to sit there front row and
watch that like if he starts getting
punched in the face i just like start to
yeah he probably will get punched in the
face he's definitely gonna get punched
in the face
that does seem to be part of it if
you're a mechanic you're going to get
dirty if you're right so you're going to
get punched
it it's it's crazy man it's an amazing
accomplishment really no matter what
happens
um so to ask you guys a crypto question
here
there's a lot of other cryptocurrencies
out there why bitcoin
why bitcoin why is it the inevitable
uh you know what reserve currency what
is what about it
do you think and what weaknesses does it
have that other cryptocurrencies may be
able to exploit
if any so i think because it's fixed
supply it makes it the ultimate store
value
it's also the first so there's a huge
first mover advantage but
no other uh cryptocurrency has the
characteristics
that make bitcoin so hard and sound why
we call it gold 2.0
okay does it have any weaknesses
as a currency is there anything that you
would i know this is not the easiest
room to
mention that in but i'm sure these guys
can handle it
i'm sure they can handle is there any
any weaknesses you could uh
imagine not really none
none okay good that's good
i think o.j simpson's innocent too
now were you worried
were you worried when it lost a lot of
value in a very in in
what seemed to be very quickly no
because it gains value quicker
more often than not that's a good point
and we think it'll be worth uh
500 000 a coin uh within the decade so
what is that price targeting it's a good
buying opportunity that's what we call
buy the dip
buy the dip 500 000 within a decade
within a decade and and and what is that
what is that based on the
the market cap of gold okay bitcoins are
better at being gold than gold if you
look at the characteristics gold's
actually
the supply of gold is is not fixed it's
actually scarce so it's increasing
uh bitcoin is actually fixed there's no
technological breakthrough that will
increase the supply of bitcoin
um so it's actually a better at being
gold than than gold and gold's market
cap right now
is 10 trillion bitcoins hovering on 1
trillion so if
bitcoin disrupts gold which we think it
will that's our thesis
then it has to be worth its market cap
has to be worth 10 trillion
which would make each bitcoin worth 500
and that's yeah that guy is
on cocaine that guy's had a lot of fun
over the last three days
that and that that makes a lot of sense
to talk about nfts for a second i know
that that i don't know if that's popular
here or not
um they're they're very interesting you
know we we had dinner we talked about
how
other cryptos and nfts are getting
people involved in the crypto space
do you see anything wrong with do you
think i mean elon musk just tweeted
something about a crypto called cummies
or come rocket
i don't know what it is okay we're not
we're not
recommending it guys relax you don't
have to boo this
is not a financial financial advice yeah
this is not financial advice
but this thing went up 30 when you
tweeted it so
is one guy having so much power
ultimately like a bad thing
yeah 100 yes right perhaps
for sure if elon musk is having a bad
day then we're all having a bad day
that certainly seems to be it we need to
switch the power we need a new a new
nominee
who can take over elon musk i like the
idea that you guys
could step in for elon musk because
there's two of you
but there's really one of you that's
what i like i like that
that's what's good it's your there's one
of you but there's two of you
so i think that's better but and i mean
i'm not asking you guys to [ __ ] on elon
musk for cheap
youtube views but
but that's what we're doing but truly
is this a problem does this hurt bitcoin
when you
when you when it can just rise and fall
on the whims of
one twitter account this is a serious
question
yeah well i think it's it's risen on its
its merits long term
you know um so bitcoin is about a
community it's a it's a movement it's a
revolution it's not about one person it
never has been
maybe in the short term it can be you
know like we're seeing but i think over
the long term
it transcends one person
okay and now i a lot of people have
gotten upset about
that it uses a lot of energy to mine but
i like that i like the earth hot
it's nice i like it hot miami's lovely
pretty hot down here
miami is lovely so i say use more energy
to mine it truly use more
i think more i think lava whatever you
want to use
if you could build bitcoin mines in
volcanoes let's [ __ ] do it
let's stop being [ __ ] truly who gives
a [ __ ]
it's nice
but
okay well this audience
is um what conference is this again
yeah this is a very strange
okay well i don't know that that relates
directly to blockchain
jake you've been talking a lot about
fighters not getting paid
let's just take a break from crypto for
a second what you got into the boxing
world you're [ __ ] it up
people are not happy and then you
started saying that
boxers are getting [ __ ] and ufc
fighters too
yeah look i mean at the end of the day
these fighters are getting
into the ring and risking their lives
you know and risking injury and it's one
of the hardest sports
if not the hardest sport in the world
and
you have to dedicate your life to it
more than more than any other sport i
believe
and people like dana white who own the
ufc are basically creating a monopoly
ufc fighters out of any organization out
of any league that there is
the owners take the most amount of the
cut versus the fighters
um which it's a big topic and
me and my brother are creating this
movement forward to help
fighters increase their pay because if
you're in the ufc your boss is dana
white so you can't be like
hey i don't think we're getting paid
fair hey this isn't right
because he'll just cut you and throw you
off to the side but
i'm i'm creating a voice for the
fighters and i'm creating a voice to say
[ __ ] dana white
fighters should be getting more pay
and they are the content you know
without them getting
into the ring the the ufc wouldn't have
the content that they sell
for hundreds of millions of dollars
these guys are getting paid
pennies on the dime and it's just not
fair
and so what i'm doing my movement
forward is showing these fighters you
don't need a promotion
you don't need a promoter and you don't
need to sign into these longer deals
create your own hype
use social media and there's going to be
a switch
in this narrative over the next couple
of years dana white
doesn't make good fights happen he
doesn't make the fights that the fans
want to see because he can't
pay these fighters enough or doesn't
want to pay these fighters enough jon
jones versus francis nagano
one of the biggest fights that everyone
wants to see he won't even pay them
10 million dollars each to make the
fight happen
versus some no name or not no name but
like some smaller boxers
will get paid 20 30 million dollars for
a fight because they're in control
of their own promotions so
yeah i just feel bad for these ufc
fighters they need to get more pay
and dana wants to want to control that
and they can't say anything
they can't speak up to their boss does
dana white like you
no no not at all he is
uh i i think he he hates me more than
anyone in the world right now
wow because look i'm i'm i'm trying to
take money out of his pocket give it to
the rest of the fighters
um you know i think he's a joke i think
he's a chump
he started off as a cardio kickboxing
instructor
instructor and got lucky with the ufc
um and now thinks he's the coolest
person on earth
um okay i'm gonna take i'm gonna take
dan
why his description of dana white why
does that also not describe elon musk
what'd you say tim like his description
dana white is like a guy like
when elon musk goes in and does all
these things he seems to be trolling and
having a lot of fun
is he ultimately a serious person do you
guys think he's
do like when he says come rocket to the
moon does he believe that
does he believe in the fundamentals of
come rocket
does he believe that come rocket has uh
is a good store of value
i mean no truly or is this guy like a
carnival
barker who's having a lot of fun and
then
on the other end there's people's lives
that he's playing with
yeah that's probably a joke but he does
own bitcoin he is a hodler as far as yes
yes i don't know if he's buying [ __ ]
rocket
right he's maybe just tweeting i don't
think that's on the balance sheet of
tesla
right right now at least but bitcoin is
i know kathy wood thinks he's long on
bitcoin and that other people are
pressuring him to
sort of to to talk about the climate
change stuff
and the mining is that true is kathy
right about all this or is she just
is she just uh saying whatever
i don't know i know that she's dating
floyd mayweather
kathy wood is dating floyd mayweather
we're here last night together i didn't
i was surprised by that
are will you guys ever sell will you
ever sell is there any
winklevoss twins right now is there any
reason that you would ever sell your
bitcoin
anything at all no
uh no unless i was buying come rocket
we are pre-recording these ads we don't
know if we're bombing at the bitcoin
conference in miami
all signs point to yes but
we'll see the companies that advertise
on the show are either a great product
that i
love or have a gang of money and usually
both to be working with me and this one
in particular is a fan of my comedy
which is why
we love working with this guy this guy
is a war criminal and he started a great
company called sheath underwear dot com
sheath underwear has a pouch for your
junk and your balls and it prevents
chafing it prevents your balls from
sitting on your leg
it's a flexible pillowcase it's all i
wear
they are the best and you have to try it
for yourself and give them a google
do some research on the inventor robert
patron
check out the story and it's interesting
if you
do not know the story of robert patron
he was a soldier
he went to iraq he was in fallujah
he was stationed by a hospital
there was a woman there have you heard
this story
there was a woman there who was about to
give birth
he literally delivered her baby
he delivered this iraqi woman's baby
and then right in front of her he shot
it in the head
sheath underwear dot com use code tim to
save 20 percent
it's a great investment sheath
underwear die and after he shot the baby
in the head
he ate it in front of her
he she grabbed the gun to try to kill
herself and him he wouldn't let her do
it
he made her watch him eat
her newborn child whom he had shot
and if that's not a guy that you can't
get behind i don't know what it is
sheath underwear dot com
robert patron um war criminal
underwear enthusiast
another famous story from his time
there was a dog that the children of
tikrit
iraq used to play with a friendly dog
that belonged to the village really
it belonged to the village and
one day robert saw all the iraqi
children playing with this dog
and robert went over and he gave the dog
what looked like a bone
but it was an explosive device and the
dog
blew up in front of the chill i'm
talking
ears i mean the children are covered in
blood and fur
these types of things make me confident
he was a leader sheath underwear dot com
saved 20 sheath underwear dot com he was
one of the first people to see abu
ghraib
prison and he went in there and
immediately he thought
that the guards were being too soft
robert patron war criminal underwear
enthusiast
sheath underwear dot com that's
s-h-e-t-h-underwear.com
use the code tim to save 20
on your order support this
man i've been eating this steak for the
last month and i love it certified
piedmontese beef
italian breed of cattle now being raised
in nebraska on our network of family
ranches
this is some of the best steak truly me
and ben have it all the time it's all
natural lean beef
but it doesn't sacrifice flavor or
tenderness so if you don't want to eat
those really fatty cuts
this is a healthier uh beef it is tender
grass-fed grass finished beef also
available
ships to all 50 states rogan loves it
it's great if you're a beefeater and and
there's a war on meat
but if you want to fight the war on meat
do it with piedmonte's beef
this is a breed of cattle brought over
from italy
it is some of the tastiest most
flavorful meat i have ever had it ships
to all 50 states
the website is cpbeef.com 25
off discount code tim dillon cpbeef.com
we had steaks the other day stop
laughing
it's ben laughs he's so stupid
because cp is like short for child porn
so he laughs like an idiot like a child
i'm trying to do my job
and do this ad and i believe in this
product because i use it and you use it
do you not eat the stuff i did
literally yesterday and just because
it's cpbeef.com
is the thing you can't get through it
with a straight face cpbeef.com
discount code tim dillon 25 off you will
not find child porn
what you will find is a great selection
of grass-fed tender cuts of meat
that's 25
off if you use the discount code tim
dillon
get your beef on how many people in here
are committed to not just buy a show of
employees not selling their bitcoin if
your mother
has been kidnapped or you're you have a
child
and they've been kidnapped do you sell
one guy says yes the rest of you are
thinking about it
that's what i like about this audience
the rest of you
are really thinking about that
applause applause applaud now
if no matter what happens with your
family you're not
selling that [ __ ] coin yeah
i respect that i respect that
mom will figure it out
she'll depend on fiat currency that
geriatric [ __ ] she'll figure it out
it's the fiat system yeah you could send
bitcoin to liam neeson's wallet and
liam neeson save your mom yes it will
it will change the narrative of every
film um
do you guys believe the financial system
in america is savable
the fiat system can it be salvaged
i mean we're printing so much money the
fed
like i think the we're running trillion
dollar deficits on a yearly basis
and i just think the math doesn't work
like at some point that
that bill or invoice comes due and i
think that it's not sustainable
right now jake you love the money system
that's why you live in puerto rico
now you explain nft you love nfts though
you're into nfts you like them
yeah 100 i think kids in our generation
uh grew up
and everything was an nft you know in
call of duty you're getting
the skins the camouflage you know
fortnight
you're changing characters those are all
nfts if you if you really think about it
and so
i think for the the younger generation
it's something that's natural something
that's built in and
you know it's art and sometimes it's art
you know right you can take with you in
your pocket right you don't need a giant
warehouse to store all this art i've
never
gone to a gallery and just been like hey
i want this piece i want this poster i
want this
but for me like going on on nifty
gateway and like
you know shopping for art and looking at
pieces that's
that's fun to me and it's and it's a
cool fun way to collect art and create
value for yourself
do you guys think both of you that nfts
will become like really
the premier type of art will digital art
replace
art i think digital art is art
you know right yeah but you know what i
mean though
do you think that where i don't think it
cannibalizes necessarily it's just a new
color it's a new medium
right you know like street art became a
thing and it wasn't but people still
like oil and canvas and
other types of art so it's just like a
new a new canvas
right the internet is your gallery
does does it seem sustainable though
because there's a lot of stuff going on
that's a little wacky
there's a lot of nfts that are that are
seemingly a bit absurd
uh where you got like lindsay lohan has
absurd too right at
that goes for a hundred grand or
something right duct tape banana at a
art basel
right that's true
it is all subjective yeah but i think
you can't bring offline
uh canvases into the metaverse and
digital world so i think that's where
nfts and digital art really flourishes
and is the dominant
my business manager is breeding nft
horses
this is true how soon until i'm homeless
i i bought a uh digital and nft
racehorse
did you yeah i told my dad and he
thought i bought a real racehorse and
his jaw dropped he's like what are you
doing
those things are really expensive and i
was like no it's not it's not
digital ones are expensive too it's true
it wasn't
how much is the digital resource if you
don't mind my asking i think it was like
fifteen thousand fifteen thousand for a
digital
racehorse it's real fast can't believe
it
it's real this guy is it is what is the
stud fee
uh for the fifteen thousand dollar
digital race 10
f right or yeah yeah i don't know
i don't know jake what is the coolest
nft you own if you're willing to share
with people
coolest thing you own that's an nft um
uh i think i i think there's a
artist named philip hodes um
i have a couple of pieces of his art
he's just fire
um that's probably the coolest thing i
i like the i like the animated like 3d
like futuristic
uh you know that's the stuff that i'm
that's that i mean like eminem's nft
that was cool i didn't see it the
marching soldiers with the skulls and
the floating stuff
ben shut up cool because like not
kidding
i'm jumping you can't put a soundtrack
on a warhol right with an nft you can
get visual
and audio together the visual the audio
form of content right it's more
immersive
yeah 100 percent moving it's
programmable like bitcoins for
programmable money it can change color
in 50 years or on your birthday or
all sorts of stuff that you can't do
offline
do you guys think that you know
governments around the world
do you see them outlawing bitcoin i know
that there's talk of that in india
i don't know if that's happened or not
um do you think that becomes
a major issue going forward that you
have governments clamping down
and do you think second part to that is
the fed
fed coin are they going to issue central
bank cryptocurrencies
i mean i would say good luck you got to
shut down the internet to shut down
bitcoin
right that's that's a tall task okay
well they'll do that so let's not
challenge you
you got it let's not be like hey china
guess what you have to do
shut down the internet they'll go
phenomenal we'll do it
north korea you just have to yeah north
korea just shut down the internet
puss oh oh you did all right oh you did
yeah that's tough but is that going to
be
an issue or do you think that the power
of the internet is so strong
i think it's too strong because the the
biggest drivers of the us economy are
the
as big tech so you cut off bitcoin you
cut off all of that
too so it's too much economic loss so
they have to work with it and live with
it
unless you want to be north korea you
guys are telling me that the internet
will be a freer place
with bitcoin that and and we look at the
internet now
and there's lots of there's lots of
challenges that creators have
censorship monetization exclusivity all
these things
how does the adoption of bitcoin
help the internet become a freer place
or maybe a less monopolized place
because we have a few
major companies that run the entire
internet
and kind of decide who can say what when
can bitcoin change that and how yeah
well so bitcoin's the blueprint for how
to decentralize anything so
ultimately the internet's very
centralized right now
but bitcoin is a blueprint to
decentralize
twitter to decentralize facebook so the
value doesn't accrue to a few people
who run those companies but rather to
the users of those networks so
think of if you tweeted instead of
getting likes um
you got paid in coin for your content
and so the value accrued to the people
who actually
used it and created the content in a
very democratic way
not just a few people sitting in offices
in
in silicon valley right and now bitcoin
will make that
easier how well
bitcoin is sets that blueprint and
bitcoin can either do that
um or it sets the blueprint for other
other um networks like
ethereum or whatnot i know that maybe
taboo for this conference it's a dirty
word
dirty word but what do you guys think
about ethereum
wow mixed reaction shocking
but the the idea is that that the all
the power
in finance and the internet rests in the
hands of a very few people
yeah um you see the game stop saga
one call to from a clearinghouse to
robin hood
so we think so we understand no we know
we know
um and and you can't trade your stock
right
there's no um the blockchain doesn't
stop you can't call the blockchain and
stop people
out it just keeps happening so
it's not a level playing field in
centralized finance
the whole world saw that they can't
unsee that
how people were stopped out um and
whatnot
and so that's pushing people into the
decentralized
alternatives like bitcoin so when we see
all the money printing and how the us
dollar what is the value of the u.s
dollar i mean
um it's it's becoming toilet paper right
right
so that's been a huge catalyst and every
time a trillion dollar
stimulus gets passed it's a trillion
dollar advertisement for bitcoin
we're burning dollars later at the after
party we're just going to take
shoe cases of us dollars and burn them
which is slightly insensitive
so when people see that happen when they
see people get the platform from
social media platforms it just pushes
people to find
alternatives and they're going to find
decentralized alternatives
where you can't beat the platform it's
not controlled by a company
a government or any person yeah and and
that's going to be the future that this
behavior
it's kind of what you're doing in
fighting in a in in a weird way like
you're coming into fighting and saying
there's this structure that exists that
kind of
[ __ ] over fighters and you're basically
saying i'm
you're gonna kind of be like a wrecking
ball and go in there and tell people
that they don't need
that structure to have a career exactly
it's like
taxi versus ubers innovating someone
someone has to do it someone has to
change the model but it's not easy it
takes time
but it's putting the power back into the
creators or
into the people who are making the
content or playing the sport
uh you know big sean has a as a song and
in the beginning of it it's like
we look at lebron james and we're like
wow he's so rich he has a billion
dollars
well how much money is he making for the
owners of the team
right so you know how how do
we as the people who are in the gym you
know training
every single day busting our asses
how do we become in control and i think
that's what the movement is for me at
least in boxing i don't know if it's
possible in basketball i don't know if
it's possible in the nfl but
boxing's very disorganized and so it's
it's something that you know this model
of basically
decentralizing does this kind of fight
is it going to work for every athlete
because you're very good at getting
attention
but a lot of those athletes that you're
saying you don't need a promoter
they might not be as good at you as
getting attention you have a massive fan
base
you're you're very good you know you'll
go out there and
you know do you think that there are
certain fighters where
they're just not going to thrive in this
medium because they don't have that
ability they won't steal someone's hat
you i mean you you got to be willing to
steal uh people's
hats you got to steal hats if you want
to make it in this sport you got to
steal
all bitcoin is is these guys are trying
to steal the federal reserve's hat
exactly right isn't that true
trying to get jerome powell's hat that's
right you crypto junkies
but there's a lot of overlap i mean
bitcoins all about empowerment of the
individual and giving people
an alternative yes system to centralize
finance
and it sounds very similar to what
you're doing if you don't have
options and you're locked into to one
thing that's not
good bitcoin gives greater choice
independence and opportunity
for individuals and i think that's why
everyone's in this room and so excited
about this technology
and movement now what do you guys where
now obviously elon tweeted and that was
a thing and there was environmental
concerns
the massive you could you know loss of
value
that happened pretty much in like a day
what do you attribute that to
was it fear was it people saying it was
it the recognition that this thing had
blown up and gained a lot of value and
there was a correction
what what were your emotions during that
period
do you care you're very stoic people
you're both of you you're very stoic
you have like kind of a stoic you're
olympians or something right didn't
weren't you in the olympics yeah maybe
it's disgusting anyway i hate the
olympics
but anyway but where you were do you do
you get do you show any
do you call him do you text him do you
go what the [ __ ] or
do you just go on a 19-mile run or
whatever you do
i mean bitcoin's died like 400 times in
the press
last 10 years so this is nothing new you
know it's like
the fud about it's all dark market stuff
and then silk road gets busted the price
goes up
you know jamie dimon calls it a fraud
warren buffett calls it rat poison like
bitcoin gets through all of this you
know and what doesn't kill it makes it
stronger so
it's one of those things it also if you
got to zoom out and have perspective we
wrote a blog
uh last summer when bitcoin saying
predicting or
you know bitcoin 500k that's our thesis
and bitcoin was trading at 13k
right so like it ran up to 60k and
crashed down to 35k
you know but it's still better than 13k
last august
so if you zoom out long enough yeah it
goes up it's a little bit boom and busty
but it's always good this is still the
best year bitcoins had
probably yes yeah but we don't even look
at the price
that much because right [ __ ] the price i
mean i see it on i see it on twitter but
like
we we know long term where it's going so
we don't get caught up in the turbulence
short term some of these people though
have borrowed against their bitcoin
right
some people have leveraged against
bitcoin like there's people in this room
right now
and some of the price going down that's
leverage coming out of the system
right sometimes like that can hit
through some stops
and you know crash the price bit more
but it it's it always recovers
right how much i mean you don't have to
say how much bitcoin you have but are
you big into the bitcoin game jake
yeah yeah i i keep trying to put more
and more
in because it's a long-term game and
i i know where it's going as well it
it's
it's the future it's the future of
currency in my
in my opinion i'm not an expert but it's
like you just see where it's gone i've
seen
where the great thing is i have to say
that we're all really experts
now it's america the year is 2021.
everyone is an expert in anything
you don't really have to ever say i'm
not an expert just
talk that's what i do i just talk
confidently and loudly and if somebody
says
that's factually wrong i go we're having
a difference of opinion
but facts really don't exist they're
stupid
and they really they hurt you if you're
trying to have a good life
this is the way i feel and do you not
feel that way as well
it's facts or old school [ __ ]
yeah never let the facts get in the way
of a good story never let the facts get
in the way of a good story
you have to just it's all about mindset
you know like and because i was
at one time near homeless and broke
but then i saw a youtube video of
garyvee and he just said win
and then i just said that's a good idea
so i started winning i didn't even know
how it just started happening it was
very inspiring he said win
damn it and i went i never tried that
so i want to thank him for that now you
you say bitcoin decentralize everything
it makes society better are there
people say hey it's used for kidnapping
hey it's used for drugs
and i and i don't mind drugs and i think
some people need to go
that's what i say about kidnapping it
makes the world fun
doesn't it when you go to an all you
conclusive resort knowing that you might
not be there the next day
makes you enjoy the goddamn day but
there are
people out there that are [ __ ]
and they keep going on about oh drugs
human trafficking blah blah blah
what's our angle here do we say no it's
not used for drugs and human trafficking
or
do we like i say defend drugs and defend
human trafficking
nothing's been used to buy more drugs
than the us dollar nothing
that's a great crime nothing has been
used and we use drugs too you can you
can't snort out of a bitcoin
i've tried you actually you can't do it
you have to roll up a dollar
or a 50 or 100 if you're having a good
night
many of you will be doing that later uh
just staring at the dogecoin dog just
but so you do you give any credence to
the criticisms of
of of bitcoin in that sense no it's just
it's a technology you know bad people
use
email and in cars part part of
kidnapping is probably involves a car
should we outlaw a car
a lot of the same people that don't like
bitcoin would say yes
there's a lot of people are you worried
about the environmental impact do you
think that there's a
renewable alternative sources that can
mine bitcoin because
that is a major concern not for me
totally because you can bring bitcoin
miners to the energy
that's stranded and not being used for
other things that you can't get to a
grid so bitcoin i think is going to
provoke a lot of renewables
um and all that stuff so i think um
yeah yeah it it will push that now when
you say you can bring bitcoin miners to
energy that's not being used that's very
interesting
where would that energy be hydro or like
natural gas
interesting stock that doesn't have a
pipeline to go anywhere that
the companies are flaring to then drill
for oil and instead of flaring it you
can use it harness it to mine bitcoin
we're actually
investors in a company called crusoe
energy that's doing that they they put
the bitcoin miners
next to these natural gas and they flare
it and use it or rather
use it in generators to then mine
bitcoin
interesting very good well
problem solved
folks the economy is going to collapse
any hour now as peter schiff
any serious investor knows you have to
allocate some of their portfolio to
precious metals specifically gold
acre gold lets you invest in physical
gold without coming out of pocket all at
once
acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month it ships to you once
you reach the price threshold with acre
taking physical delivery of your gold
means it's safe and sound and in your
hands acre ships your gold directly and
discreetly to your door
acre designs their gold in california
and sources their gold
from one of the largest mints in
switzerland it's actually really
interesting because acre gold
is one of the few affordable tangible
things you can buy that will be worth
anything in five years that part blew my
mind
the big takeaway here is that you don't
have to come all up out of pocket all at
once
to acquire meaningful gold i'm doing
this right now and i think it's great
get acre gold.com
tim dillon start investing in physical
gold today getakergold.com tim dillon
make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a free gold
bar
to qualify for this giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
recipient i guess you could lie
and mention at get underscore acre
that's at
get underscore acre get underscore acre
again that's getacre gold.com tim dillon
we love acre gold it's a great idea if
you want to start diversifying
your portfolio into the original crypto
gold great hedge against inflation
always a good investment thank you acre
gold
for supporting the show covert spring
break is right around the corner you
know what that means spring break your
pants
manscaped is here to ensure the party in
your pants never stops
even veronica corningstone wouldn't say
no to the pants party for everyone
preparing for a pants party this spring
break
i have an exclusive 20 off discount go
to manscape.com
everybody needs manscaped get the
lawnmower 3.0 waterproof cordless body
trimmer
to shape up your junk they've got all
kinds of cool stuff it's the best
trimmer on the market for those of you
in need
of a chest or ball shave third
generation trimmer features cutting age
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents
thanks to advanced skin safe technology
pioneered by manscaped
don't ruin any vibes this spring break
or upcoming summer with some peeking
pubes coming out of your swimsuit
although people like that you'll also
find the crop reviver ball toner a
spray-on testy toner that's designed to
give your boys
a little slice of heaven for a limited
time subscribers get two free gifts
the shed travel bag 39 value ad and the
patented high performance reduced
chafing
manscape boxers get 20 off free shipping
by going to manscape.com
tim d manscape dot com
slash tim d 20 off and free
shipping how cool is that manscape.com
say aloha to your new beautiful balls
with manscaped
jake your next fight
coming up which is against
a ufc fighter some people have
criticized you and said
we need we want them to start fighting
boxers what do you say to those people
look i say uh i'm here to do big
fights you know there's not that many
boxers that have big names unfortunately
there's a lot of ufc fighters with big
names and so
i'm doing fights that make sense from a
business standpoint my goal is to sell
millions of pay-per-views and make
history and make it as hype as possible
and i'm fighting the big name people and
tyrone woodley's a significant striker
he you know he's a five-time ufc
champion
he has brutal knockout power he's
knocked out almost all of his opponents
and if you look at the careers of like
mike tyson or floyd mayweather muhammad
ali
in their fourth fight this is my fourth
fight coming up
in their fourth fight they're fighting
guys who nobody has heard of who are
owen five if you know anything about the
sport of boxing
your promoter you know takes you from
when you're a young kid
and he has you fight a bunch of easy
people until you're
20-0 and then all of a sudden you're
this big star and you can get paid
millions of dollars for fights
but you're realistically you're 20-0
against guys with with no names you
haven't fought any world champions
my last fight was against a world
champion an olympic athlete
uh two-time dan hodges ncaa wrestling
division one champion award winner
and i knocked him out in one round yeah
he seemed tired that guy
he seemed uh
he did it yeah
his training video was weird he was like
running in the snow i'm like oh he's
gonna be in
trouble that's like rocky right rocky do
you think
would you ever could you beat both
winklevoss twins
that's tough they're athletes they're
eight feet tall
they own more bitcoin than god it's
very tough look
i don't want to be an [ __ ] but
you are an amazing what people don't
understand is like you're a legit legit
fighter
you're legit athlete you take it
seriously this is what you want to do
you don't want to [ __ ] with youtube
anymore in the way that you used to
you're bored with that you want to be a
fighter 100 like yeah i take it more
seriously than
99.9 of fighters do you know i have a
10 person staff just for my boxing team
from
three boxing coaches to a mind coach
to a stretching coach two strength and
conditioning coaches like the list goes
on and so i take it very very seriously
and
everyone wants to see the you know jake
paul get
knocked out and so i have a giant chip
on my shoulder
and when you when you combine that with
a hard work ethic you know i grew up
wrestling in state in division one ohio
one of the hardest wrestling states
playing football i wanted to go to the
nfl i can run a 4.4 second
40 yard dash i i i want to win i have a
will to win i have a chip on my shoulder
and i have the best team
surrounding me and i've grinded in the
dark
to shine in in the light and right
uh i i'm i'm just
i love the sport i'm ready i've said
that many times
when checking into a hotel and they say
your room is not ready i said i've
grinded in the dark
to step into the light and they go not
till four
you're not stepping in the light till 4
pm
and it's a real problem look of us
what's the price target for bitcoin
before the end of the year and we're
gonna quote you on this
and if you're wrong we're gonna do
nothing
so make sure you're careful by the end
of the year by january where does
bitcoin close does it fall
further or the other one where it goes
higher
i think we could see a hundred thousand
um
there's more in this uh this cycle yeah
is that from both of you yes
okay good
do you think there's do you think
ethereum
is other than bitcoin does that seem to
be
the one crypto that has real staying
power
yes yes i agree
very good
they're so nervous they're saying like
two words
because people care what they say now
the middle east no i'm kidding uh
palestine just announced they're buying
bitcoin right after all sovereignty so
it's turning around now
[Laughter]
are there any issues that you anticipate
uh with government the irs is now
getting involved in this
you know this they're they're clamping
down
why are they doing this and should we
overthrow the government
why do you think they're doing this do
you think that they think people are
getting away with money or is this
is this a more of a anti-bitcoin posture
that the government is taking is it a
money grab that the government
needs money or do you think it's part of
something larger
i don't think it's singling out crypto
it's just the government likes to take
your money
with taxes so it could be some kind of
deep state thing who knows yeah
if if there was one
coin outside of a fun one
not a bitcoin not an ethereum a fun coin
a fun coin from everyone on the thing
what
fun coin do you like is it come rocket
is it [ __ ] coin is it as coin
i i think the coins that are
uh donating to charity
you know as a part of their that's a
part of their donating
i like that charity is relying upon
come rocket for donations
i think that's a good system we have but
are there coins donating to charity
yeah there's like there's there's pit
bully for example where you know a lot a
large part
of their liquidity gets donated to
prevent against bullying
what's the name of that pit bully pit
bully
yeah and
wait a minute it has nothing to do with
pit bulls
i think the logo is a pit bull okay
it's a violent dog now so
part of the their liquidity gets donated
to bullies
i like that and it took they give it or
no it's donated to the victims of
bullying
correct yeah okay
oh tim well i'm glad what about you guys
is there any fun coin do you have any
fun with the coins
you're so respected and legitimate say
something
insane so that we can get views so i
don't
fire my [ __ ] agent for sending me
down here
i'm kidding it's been fun we've had a
lot of fun i i like
i like this it feels deeply like a
religion now
which is healthy i think it is i think
mass psychosis is good and other people
don't but i think there's something nice
about a group of people
who believe things no matter what no
matter what the facts
are it's good to have a group of people
completely impervious to any logic
or outside information i think it's good
now are there any other coins that you
guys have fun with
i mean i tweet about doge a lot but i
don't own any so
you don't own any dogecoin not yet what
about you
no what about you jake i mean you got
i mean i think everyone messes around
with with [ __ ] coins a little bit
yeah but i i i was in doge yeah before
elon talked about it
right [ __ ] coins are like [ __ ]
but
not sex workers which are great [ __ ]
sex workers it's a legit we get it but
so the [ __ ] goes like [ __ ] and but you
marry the bitcoin and then you also
that's what you do you marry the bitcoin
and then
you [ __ ] ethereum once a year
and your wife doesn't mind because you
have a pool
that's kind of am i wrong about that
i think i'm kind of right about that
well we're gonna wrap this up soon
because there's an after party
uh where uh elon will show up if elon
had balls he would come to this
convention
i i believe that right
man this audience has the energy of the
capital riot
i mean it's like i'm so scared that
there's not a [ __ ] glass partition
between these two security guys what are
they gonna do
these people just stormed the stage and
[ __ ] kill us all
they'll tweet about it like yeah that
sucked anyway
jake paul is getting eaten alive by some
[ __ ] crypto freaks
in a [ __ ] convention set i'm glad we
can't afford a real convention center
we're here in this [ __ ] weird art
installation
nothing makes you feel good about the
future of a financial product and
walking by [ __ ] white chicks with
dreadlocks on the street
who are painting [ __ ] murals on the
wall
it's like the fed versus street art it's
like great
good next year we'll get the real
convention center
any parting words of wisdom this is an
army of people out there
there there may be losing faith in
bitcoin maybe they've lost money
who knows is there any anything that you
guys can say is your final closing
argument of like hey
times are tough they might get tougher
is there anything that you because you
guys are relatable figures you're a
billionaire
tall athletic olympians just like
everyone else in this country now
so talk to your equals out there
your equals that are watching you on
youtube going those guys and me
we get it friends of mine
unemployed uber drivers morbidly obese
drug addicts people that own
1 18th of a bitcoin and look at you and
go i'm gonna be them
even your last name is kind of magical a
little bit
winklevoss it just sounds if i said that
was my last name somebody would go
no it's not they'd go no it's not
and i'd go you're right so is there any
inspiring message you have
for the monsters out there on the other
end of their
screen looking at you going bitcoin's my
way out what do you say to them
always stack sats and remember to always
huddle
and buy the dip and buy the dead
okay jake what words of wisdom do you
have for
people on tick tock right now that are
going to be irrelevant in 15 minutes
who who want to start fighting people
because it's their only hope
they go i got to fight people now
i mean you and your brother are like
you're like the leaders of that
that section of the internet where it's
like now everybody's fighting tick
tockers youtubers the demilio girls are
kicking each other in the face
what do you what do you tell people that
want to have a career on the internet as
you've had
what do you tell those people out there
because you're a relatable guy
you were you grew up in ohio you were a
landscaper
and now you own the island of puerto
rico so what do you say to those people
i would say uh
you're [ __ ] i would say don't do it
yeah don't do it don't do it
that's what i tell them about comedy
don't do it stick to your day job
well that's an inspiration i could say
something inspiring but i wouldn't
that's
what i like that's what i love about you
you're not full of [ __ ]
you don't tell people it's gonna work
out
you did a lot of [ __ ] you jumped on a
lot of trampolines you grabbed a lot of
hats
you [ __ ] worked your ass off you know
these people rode a lot everyone worked
what is this guy this guy's do you have
a gun i'm kidding anyway
oh this is this is a terrifying audience
this is the scariest audience i've
i've performed it like heavy metal
concerts
and this audience is much scarier
belief in anything is really terrifying
that's what i've learned you know but i
love i love being here i think bitcoin
is going to bounce back
i say it's wrong that people call it a
financial q anon
i think i
our podcast sucks you suck
listen buddy you you're a good person
and you're angry and i don't know why
you're angry but
it's probably because you're involved in
a cult
and you need to get out of that cult and
do something else
the meaning that you're looking for in
life you're not going to find in a
convention center in miami
that's not even real right after you
people leave they move the homeless
right back in here
truly right after you guys leave they
move homeless people back in here and
then they get up here and talk about
bitcoin
that's all that happens but anyway thank
you that's give it up for elon musk's
brother
that's that's kimball musk everybody my
name is tim dillon
give it up for jake paul the winklevoss
twins thank you guys so much
good luck
[Music]
thank you guys